abstractions took us far they let us
notice common features of objects throw
away their differences and end up with a
general concept but now that you have
that abstraction tell me what are you
going to do with it once you see common
properties and abstract them you aren't
limited to applying your abstraction to
the original objects that sparked it you
can find those same properties in new
objects and in new situations this lets
you learn it lets you gain knowledge
we've used the abstract round to work
out formulas that apply to every round
thing let's say I tell you I have a new
round thing in my backpack that you've
never seen before in your life
since you don't know what it is how
could you possibly be able to tell me
anything about it
well my friend once you've mastered
abstract thinking you see right past
this charade we can use the same kind of
abstract thinking to pick up on patterns
and language there's something else in
my backpack you've never seen before
it's a creature called a schhwaff but I
bet you already know exactly what to say
when you see three of them don't you
when you do that you're drawing on a
past pattern you've seen in English
abstracting that pattern and applying it
to this new instance you've never had to
say that you've seen three Schweppes
before in your life
but by taking a pattern from your source
and applying it to a target the answer
was obvious
if you've taken your fair share of
standardized tests you've come across
comparisons like this these puzzles are
called analogies more specifically this
is a proportional analogy and it tests
how good we are at abstracting the
meaning of one pair of words and
applying it to the second pair but
analogies like this might have even more
to teach us about language and thought
think about it doesn't the schhwaff
schhwaff thing work a little like one of
these analogies if so just how far can
we take analogies in our quest to learn
and think and create you'll see this
pattern of recognizing a pattern
abstracting the properties of that
pattern and applying that abstraction to
a new instance over and over again oh we
might even call this a pattern of
analogies but how do we abstract that
and analogize those abstractions
thanks for taking the time to learn with
me
you